- On this episode, I get
reconnected with an old friend,
I talk about self-esteem,
and ya govoryu po russki.
(hip hop music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
And you're watching the
#AskGaryVee show episode 18.
Little fun fact about 18,
the Jets had an 18 point
lead in Green Bay on Sunday
and blew it.
- [Voiceover] Thomas
asks, what forms of media
do you consume and are
there any particular people
you listen to?
- Thomas, how are you?
Thank you for the opening
question on episode 18,
little bit a better mood for me than 17.
I consume a lot of Twitter, predominantly.
A little bit of Facebook newsfeed,
a little bit of espn.com.
I actually consume a shockingly
low percentage of media
and as it comes to following people,
who do I listen to?
Again, I really don't really pay attention
to a whole lot of taste
makers or notable figures.
I'm very within.
I'm very selfishly stuck in my cocoon.
But this is where I'm gonna
throw you for a curveball
and I do think it's a differentiator.
I spend an obnoxious, heavy amount of time
listening to my community.
Last night, after lots of meetings,
right before bed, instead
of consuming stuff
as the normal marketplace does,
I was reading the comments
that a lot of you left for me
in yesterday's episode.
It is more interesting to me
to understand what my,
the people that I'm lucky enough
to give me their attention,
what they're looking for from me,
a little bit about their life.
I know that Chef Lizette
is moving to New York.
I'm consuming my community
which I think is me repaying
what you're paying me with
which is your attention.
I'm giving you back my attention and so
I haven't anchored myself,
maybe out of pride or bravado or ego
to other taste makers or leaders.
I don't do that at all.
It keeps me fresh in some way.
It continues to allow me to be in my lingo
and I don't really wanna be affected.
I'm very in my zone so my
consumption is quite low.
I read Techmeme, Jason Hirschhorn's email
for like what's in the news,
but I'm not consuming much
and I'm not following much except for you.
- Gary, should I still
pursue a degree in marketing
when you say, even though you say,
marketers ruin everything.
- I'm a marketer.
- If not, then what should I pursue
in regards to my career?
'Cause I really want to work in marketing
but approach it differently
than it's been done
in the past several years.
- Giann, first and foremost,
I like how you were reading
some sort of card over here.
I'd eliminate that from your game
but I'm not razzing.
Marketers do ruin everything
and I'm a proud and happy marketer.
So, don't take that literally.
I think you should pursue marketing
and I love that you're trying to,
look the fact that you even know who I am
and are asking a question
on the #AskGaryVee show,
believe it not, makes me think
you're gonna be successful.
And, what I would recommend,
is the degree's nice and all,
but I would highly recommend
if you're still in university,
to intern at the places that
you most think are innovating.
I mean, when I think
about the last two classes
of VaynerMedia interns and the fact
how many of them get hired
into this organization
and how great VaynerMedia is
as an organization by comparison
to the other people that are marketing
as agencies out there and
I really believe that.
I think they were very smart, strategic,
and made the right move.
I would give you the same recommendation.
Get into the walls that
you most believe in
and you should market in a different way
and 99% of the places right now
won't allow you to do that
so find the other five,
six, seven, 10 places
that look like this place
which will create the
culture to allow that.
- [Voiceover] Carlos asks,
curious how you feel about
the impact you've made
on people you've touched
and inspired over the years.
- Carlos thank you so
much for that question.
It's very sweet.
You know, a lot of you really know me
because you've been following my career
for quite a while and
we interact quite a bit
and I think I'm more
tangibly and touchable
than a lot of the other kind
of people that look like me
and we engage quite a bit
and I have a lot of contacts,
back to question number one,
in comparison to others and
all that, blah, blah, blah,
but the truth is, most of you don't
really, really, really know me
and I think that, you
know, with the hustler
and businessman and the north star
of buying the New York Jets,
one would say, he loves
and wants to buy the Jets
more than anything and thus,
the money associated with that process
is very important to him.
It is a distant second to
know that I've been gifted
with a communication
style that touches people,
that makes them, you know,
maybe I'm saying the same
thing they've heard before,
it's either my conviction
or it comes from my soul
in such a way, I talk about
what I believe in so much
that it's been able to move people.
Crush It! was clearly a catalyst
'cause that book really
did move people's careers.
So many of you have been affected.
It blows my mind actually to think about
how many people have been affected
even in small ways.
Creating more positivity for some people
and there's just so many variables
of how I've affected people
and I don't say that in like,
look at how cool I am,
I'm just so goddamn thankful, you know.
It's, you know, so how
do I think about it?
I think it is my legacy.
I think it is the essence
of who I am as a human being
and it is the singular thing
that I'm most proud of.
And it gives me enormous confidence
of what kind of parent I'm going to be
and that makes me very, very happy.
- So um, you know, Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
uh, uh, you know, my
question for you is this,
uh, um, do you speak Russian?
(speaking Russian)
And for all of you that
don't understand that,
that was Russian with a
very heavy English accent
predicated on the notion
that it was important
for my parents to become Americanized
and so we didn't live in Brooklyn
in Brighton Beach with
all the other Russians.
We went to New Jersey.
We were very proud to become Americans
and very much pushed English
language in the home.
- [Voiceover] Mrs. Jones asks,
how do you make sure lack of confidence
doesn't stop me from chasing my dreams?
Mrs. Jones, this is a very
important question to me
because I'm actually quite scared
to give you the answer which is
we need to seriously think about
how to build up your confidence.
I am the the kind of person that believes
that self-esteem is the
ultimate drug in society.
And I believe that when
you have self-esteem,
you give yourself the
audacity to dream big
aka buy the New York Jets.
When you dream big, what ends up happening
is the little things
stop mattering as much
and you're not crippled by them
and you start really kind of becoming,
you know, I'm actually maybe the least
anxious person I know
in a world where anxiety
should be, on paper,
the thing that I most
have 'cause I have so much
going on and I have these
enormous aspirations.
You know, I really
struggle with this question
because I would actually tell you
to not say, well don't worry
about it, you'll get there.
And no rah-rah I can do real quick here
is going to affect you,
but what I'm hoping to affect you with is
I would highly recommend
doing some deep searching
into what you can afford
and what is practical to work on that
whether that's literally
seeing somebody to build it up,
mapping your life backwards,
surrounding yourself with
positive, self-esteem driven
people, I think is a
very unique way to do it.
This is the big one for
me fellas and ladies.
I am all in on self-esteem
and I would say if you
are self-aware enough
to know that you lack it,
I would tell you to execute about
finding a way to gain more of it.
- I'm loving the show, like loving it.
Great to see you back.
I hope you remember me from
Wine Library episode 759
where we drank out of bottles.
Enough of that, my question.
I run a video blog inmymug.com.
Plug, got the plug in.
- Smart plug.
- And get about 5,000 views a week
but we've been kind of there
for the last 100 or so episodes.
Should I kick on, should
I be bothered about that?
We get in sales from it, we
get lots of interaction from it
but should I kick on and if I am,
should I look at dark posts,
should I look at Twitter?
What should I kind of do to kind of
find that next level?
And thank you for the show.
- My pleasure, my friend.
I definitely, definitely remember you
and that was a lot of fun.
You know, it's funny I
was just about to segway
in closing off the show about,
I also want more viewers
and I wanna keep building, like,
when you're in the game,
you're in the game.
You wanna build.
And you've done the patience thing
which is normally my answer.
That's my answer to me.
I'm only 18 episodes in
and you gotta restart
and rebuild an audience
and get people used to behavior
and it's not email or RSS
like I had with Wine Library
back in 06, 7, 8 and
so it's different ways.
It's Twitter but that's
noisier and different.
You know, so, I would say distribution.
The reason you're stuck right now
is you need distribution,
distribution, distribution.
I highly recommend you say to yourself,
what are the 100 websites
that are the biggest websites in the world
that speak to or are in
the genre of my show?
And then literally email them one by one
and ask them if they want the rights
to distribute your content
with maybe you writing on top of it.
I'd also reach out to the top 100 podcasts
that you can get out there
on and promote the show.
Give interviews, you need to hustle.
What you just did by
getting on this show worked.
You were gonna pick up 39, 42, 73
new listeners for your
show by being on this show.
And you need to just scale
the living crap out of that.
It's hustle, hustle, hustle,
hustle, hustle, hustle
hustle, hustle, but with
a thread in distribution.
You need more awareness.
You need to show up on other
YouTube celebrity's show.
You need to get into
the LinkedIn community
and start putting out that content.
You need to get the hell out there.
That is the game, my friend.
And that is a nice way to
kind of wrap up the show
'cause that's what I was
gonna rant about at the end.
Question of the day, been working on it.
A lot of you have answered.
I really appreciate your feedback
you did in the last episode.
What do you think about
the new garyvaynerchuk.com?
Right here, right here.
Put some work into it.
We're on the back of RebelMouse,
one of my investments,
a platform I really believe in
and I'd love your three cents on that.
You keep asking questions,
I will keep answering them.
Layers, baby, layers.
And that's it, episode
18 in the books, guys.
Oh, that's not it.
We have one more video question
and ironically, I was
about to talk about it
so let's go to it.
(hip hop music)